you know okay because I think sometimes
it's just like the simple things do you
know what it was so when I became a monk
right I think the hardest like period of
that was like the first week where you
either like fully commit or just kind of
like breaks you and you're just like no
I won't Comfort my life you know like
the thing that like got me this close to
my breaking points
cold showers
[Applause]
you get used to them pretty quickly I've
never done it but apparently you can you
get adjusted to it
I never did I know no I got adjusted to
sleeping on a concrete floor actually uh
without a pillow that was that actually
you know that was yeah something that I
just do pretty quickly uh I never got
used to coach owls now that was like
yeah if I was a monk I would I would
quit after three days and then just
chill out in the city for a few months
then come back to my family like dude it
was crazy it was so fun it's uh yeah the
whole uh the whole praying part was
really sick
uh yeah like it was it for me it was
like cool Charles if I if I go to a
place and we had one place in our
America Tour that had a broken shower as
well that wasn't just broken that was
like a horror shower yeah it was and I
don't know if we said this on the
episode but like it was on the fourth
floor of a building that had no elevator
and the every single thing it was in LA
every single floor you go higher it got
more derelict and like dirt fresh and
the floor with the shower was had
cobwebs everywhere no light yeah no
light bulbs yeah and when you get in the
shower room it's just this small
concrete little Alleyway that's like
narrowing towards the shower it's really
creepy and then just a military like bed
propped up on the side of the wall and
you go in the shower and it's [__]
freezing yeah dribbling yep and so
you're like in this [__] cold ass
dribbling shower and then you want to
get out of it and you can't even dry
yourself properly because the floor is
so dirty and you can't step out because
it's gonna [__] matter or anything it
was horrible yeah yeah this is this is
one of the most expensive cities in the
world I remember I just took one look
and I was just like yeah I'm just gonna
stay smelly like I don't care I don't
know why I was like I have to shower
yeah I regret it so much [__] uh that
was the moment that almost like I'm
never touring again like this really
yeah yeah I had a [__] that broke me
yeah that actually broke me that shower
I was like I actually actually made me
want to not tour anymore I'm done yeah
which is uh which you know you know
that's at the time uh it almost right
but it didn't break us because we did
the Europe tour yeah no cold showers in
the Europeans the showers in the Europe
tour were great yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly it was great so that's all I
need just give me like a nice hot shower
get my day started that's why okay
here's the thing uh uh I don't know if
we've told the story but when we did our
Japan road trip it was either me or manu
that was always late to every to
everything and the reason is
we I needed a shower to wake up that was
like why can't you take short showers
gone that okay let's you need you can't
just have a short shower you you
actually just killed it out I can do it
one minute shower I could be in and out
that doesn't count that doesn't count
you know what you know when you you can
get clean you know you know when you uh
soap applies you know when it's not
about getting clean
it's not about it literally about
getting it
it's actually just about getting less
why we shower that is okay that is why
we shall that is one of the reasons
that's not the like the only reason that
that's that's the reason why I take
shelves before I go to bed so that I can
take my time with my shower if I needed
to have a shower in the morning it's
always going to be quick I literally had
a 40 second shower I think today oh my
God I can't imagine no no no no it
couldn't be me oh 40 seconds I think I
ran the shower longer to heat it up than
I was actually in it oh I literally sped
on it I was like water armpits soap full
full course done you wake up first thing
and you're just like you just let the
water run and you're just like all right
you're just getting ready for the day
there was like there was like six of us
waiting to use one shower and God's like
well God's gone in all right guys we'll
give up on the shower I mean I I could
ask you what's the point of taking a
bath baths are just less efficient
showers yeah I completely agree with you
they're gone and I'll do that if I have
the time which is the key factor here
which we did not have the time on the
Japan special yeah the other thing that
pissed us off during the Japan trip was
not the fact that you were taking long
showers it was the fact that it was like
okay so meeting at the lobby we're gonna
leave early it's like 8 30 you know 8 30
meet up at the lobby and God's like
perfect I'll start my shower at 8 30.
okay so I was getting to this so you
should never room me with Manu ever
again because we have like the same
mentality because I was like the reason
I'm starting my shower at 8 30 was
because Maddie was taking a 15 minute
shower I'm gonna call God out out of all
three of us God is always late to
everything yeah now he's on his own time
zone
I don't know uh difference just average
15 minutes [__] hell that's a that's
a four course okay that makes sense mine
mine is roughly 10 to 15. I normally do
five five I'm like 10 minutes okay
anyway gone is always late to everything
uh no it's not like super late it'll
gone will just always be five or ten
minutes
consistently five to ten minutes late to
everything why are you never on time
gone what's your reason it's because I
need those showers no you can't always
use this excuse me
or something
we all make a joke that we're like
whatever the time is talgon it 15
minutes earlier so that gaunt shows up
on time
we've done this a few times
where it's like okay uh so 11 at the
office tomorrow right it's like okay
great it's like all right Nabi tell gone
to meet at 10 45. and then you get there
at 11. it's funny like I like I'm more
likely to be on time if I have to like
travel far to a place yes I know this I
know this yeah I've noticed this about
you if it's if I'm like really close to
a place or if I know I can get there at
any time something my brain's just like
no I understand yeah yeah I get that but
but when I have to like schedule it out
I'm like okay I need to be there [__]
half an hour early yeah but what annoys
us the most is like say we're meeting up
at the the office at 11 right and then
you know Conor I will like text the
group being like God where you at and
then you'd be like I'm getting ready and
I'm like when we said 11. we don't mean
start getting ready at 11. we mean get
your ass here by 11. okay so normally on
office days I I do have like that 10
o'clock meeting uh which might might
have played like a big factor yeah but I
was like I'll be honest guys I'm I'm
trying to like uh if if do this
efficiently for me this is this is a me
thing I'm like it's absolutely so we all
have to have like weekly Geeks plus
meetings and I'm like let's do it like
an hour before a trash Chase meeting you
know the boys will understand you know
I'm I'm trying to do this
[Music]
but I stick my I stick by the showers
okay I'm like that I'm like you know I'm
like a [__] Windows computer that
doesn't have like an SD drive you know I
I you switch it on and he needs like 15
like 5-15 minutes in the shower just
like food up you say SD drive uh
I'm on like the old [__] hard drives
you know the [__] mechanical ones I'm
like really loud ones how do you just
like see like the Windows XP logo and
you're like all right you need a bit of
time to wake up to get the day started
sharing for less than five minutes may
not be long enough to cleanse your body
I'm not saying it's ideal but if you got
to do it you got to do it all right
because let's be honest we're just
trying to get rid of the stink markers
obviously with a dirty you know what I
mean but like a lot of times I'm just
trying to get rid of the smell of you
you know so yeah but it's 40 seconds
enough to get rid of the smell I think
if you show up
listen I I would love a shower but
sometimes you have to do a one minute
shower no because I shower before I go
to bed like a comment like like a sane
post I can't win I can't win can I I
give a reasonable rationale as to why
you might have to do a shortage I think
all the time I want I'm going to bed
I'm not gonna be like [__] I need to go
to bed 40 seconds in the shower no
longer I just want to get a gold split
sometimes okay I just wanna I need to be
in bed on the dot I'm I'm gonna do my
name am I getting my new goal in life is
to do the quickest possible shower I
need a time let's just Speed Run yeah
it's literally it's literally from the
moment you step in it's like how quickly
can I do it
yeah just shower 80 no skips also got to
be with us with a block of syrup that
just seems more exciting that that could
definitely be a speed running dropping
the soap is
that's what run did I can't wait for the
summoning salt video